why has it taken this long for companies
like microsoft to realize video game
subscription services are going to be
the future of their entire industry
[Music]
[Applause]
let's examine three key things that have
changed over the last decade that have
quite literally changed the game first
it was broadband speeds and hard drive
capacities
a modern game can take up storage space
of more than a hundred gigabytes for
context an entire movie streaming an
ultra hd 4k on say disney plus might be
between 10 and 20 gigabytes before now
file sizes like that were just too
cumbersome to download for the mass
market to want to do so and it meant box
copies remained a popular alternative
but in developed markets with gigabit
fiber optic connections and unlimited
download quotas it's just not a
roadblock anymore some console games can
be played as they're installing because
the device simply downloads the
beginning of the game first
game streaming further negates the
problem as services like xbox cloud
gaming playstation now nvidia's geforce
now they just stream the game to you in
real time as you play no download in
advance required
the second thing that's changed is
mobile in-app payments and bear with me
here when apple and google began letting
companies give away their apps for free
and monetize them with in-app upgrades
and features they slowly but
comprehensively redesigned how consumers
approach sampling and committing we have
entirely become used to being drawn into
compelling screenshots or descriptions
and downloading an app or a game or a
service and enjoying it for free for a
while
games account for the majority of
spending on mobile app stores and most
of that is within games that were free
to try in the first place with the
broadband speed and storage issues
removed it makes sense for this try
don't buy model to absorb console and pc
gaming as well
the third change is of course a
wholesale shift in consumer sentiment
towards subscription in general the
model just works giving me access to
everything and i'll pay you every month
to get off my back
investors love it too as it's much
easier to forecast growth and less risky
than relying on a single big title every
year to bring in all the money
and when you add in the back catalog
games and games from older consoles and
pc generations it's the icing on the
cake for consumers as far as value is
concerned
which brings us to today and why
companies like microsoft are buying up
studios like zenimax bethesda activision
yes it's for the call of duties and
skyrims to drive new subscriptions but
it's also for vast back catalogs of
older games to pad out subscription
catalogs with options to keep people
paying and playing
for microsoft in particular it's also a
way to bolster its azure cloud
architecture which powers the xbox
gaming service
with hindsight it was inevitable the
subscription model would take over in
video games but there are some
unanswered questions to look out for for
instance sony's strategy has always been
to stick to releasing great games that
exclusively require its consoles as a
way of attracting users
could sony keep people buying
playstations if they knew they could
access an xbox streaming catalog or vice
versa
also many major games come in two three
or more expanded or ultimate editions so
as part of the game subscription you get
the basic title but if you want all
those extra levels or costumes or
weapons you need to pay a little extra
to the developer to unlock them
this does already happen of course but
mobile gaming has shown us that's a door
that could be opened even wider
where do you stand on game subscriptions
do you prefer to buy outright still let
me know on social media for quick take
in london i'm nate langston and i've
been technically gaming